Apple has finally updated their MacBook
Pros for 2019 and quite a few people
seem to be confused on which
configuration they should buy so we
decided to make this video highlighting
10 mistakes you should avoid when making
your purchase and stick around in to the
end to see which configurations we
recommend for each use case the first 5
mistakes have to do with the new 15-inch
MacBook Pro so let's get into mistake
number one when buying the 8 core
MacBook Pro don't spend the extra 200
dollars on the 2.4 gigahertz CPU upgrade
because the 2.3 gigahertz processor is
already in a nine and in the rear world
cinema jar 20 benchmark we got a score
of three thousand 161 points
snazzy labs tests of the 2.4 gig a core
processor and he score 2231 points
that's only a two percent higher score
for $200 so we don't recommend anyone to
make that upgrade onto mistake number
two if you're planning on getting the 8
core processor start by selecting the
$2,800 model that already comes with the
8 core instead of choosing the $2,400
model and up getting to the a core
afterwards the reason is that it makes
you upgrade straight to the 2.4
gigahertz CPU for $300 more and at that
point you're already at $2,700 and you
only get a 256 gig SSD up getting to 512
brings the price up to $2,900 so just
choose the $2,800 model from the very
beginning which comes with the 512
gigabyte SSD and of course the 8 core
CPU for the third mistake don't upgrade
the graphics if you're a photo editor or
you're doing work that's heavily
dependent on the processor we've tested
it many times before and upgrading
graphics literally does nothing for
photo editing so just keep whatever
graphics comes with your configuration
the fourth mistake that people make is
not upgrading the RAM and choosing to
throw their extra cash on something else
like the processor or graphics instead
especially for photo editing or similar
workloads yes it's a $400 upgrade but
it's well worth it we tested the 2018
MacBook Pros and found that the biggest
factor for photo editing was actually
the RAM so prioritize ram if you've got
extra cash now the fifth mistake is made
by video editors for graphics renders
who choose not to buy the vega 20
traffic's we've seen massive boosts in
everything from video editing to gaming
performance and even a small jump and
processor performance just going from
Radeon 560 X graphics to Vega 20 if
you're a video editor with extra cash
pay for Vega 20 before any other upgrade
the only downside is that Apple makes
you buy the $2800 8 core model in order
to upgrade to Vega 20 but it's
definitely worth it
Apple has also updated the 13-inch
MacBook Pro for 2019 so let's take a
look at the five mistakes people make
when buying that model for mistake
number six people don't realize that the
$12.99 and 1499 models haven't been
updated at all since 2017 meaning they
still pack outdated seventh gen
dual-core processors and the second gen
butterfly keyboard that's been having so
many issues recently it's sad that Apple
hasn't updated it so we recommend going
for the 2018 MacBook Air instead if you
can't afford the $1,800 2019 model
mistake number 7 is that some people
think the new 13-inch MacBook Pro packs
Intel's latest ninth gen processors but
it doesn't it still packs the same 8th
gen processors from before they're just
clocked slightly higher so why did Apple
do this well it turns out that the 19
quad-core processors don't come with the
faster Intel iris plus graphics which
are badly needed on this machine so
Apple just stuck with a gen if you want
9 gen go for the 15-inch now on to
mistake number 8 don't pay the extra
$300 to go from the base I 5 to i7
processor it really won't make much of a
difference at least not $300 worth a
couple of years back I 7 meant that you
get hyper threading but these days I
fives get it as well so the only
difference is a clock speed boost so
just stick to the base CPU on the
13-inch to avoid mistake number 9 make
sure to use any extra cash you have on
upgrading to 16 gigabytes of RAM over
anything else 8 gigabytes is really low
in 2019 and upgrading RAM will benefit
you in everything from web browsing to
photo and video editing and basically
everything else so if you're gonna
upgrade one thing upgrade the RAM
however it be careful not to spec out
the 13-inch MacBook Pro with a bunch of
upgrades which brings us to our final
mistake
some people speculate inch with 16
of RAM in the faster processor for
$2,300 not realizing that the $2,400
15-inch MacBook Pro gives you a massive
improvement for only $100 more yes you
get the larger 15-inch screen but you
also get 16 gigs a faster 2400 megahertz
ddr4 Ram a much faster nice Gen 6 core
processor instead of the eighth Gen 4
core and you actually get a dedicated
graphics chip which destroys the 13-inch
MacBook Pros integrated graphics this
will make a huge difference for video
editors so with all that out of the way
let me give some recommendations for
each use case if you're a user who does
simple stuff like web browsing school or
business work are using web-based apps
we recommend just going for the base
$1200 2018 MacBook Air since you won't
really be using the extra power that the
MacBook Pro provides now if you do a
little bit of photo or video editing
maybe some rendering programming or
producing any kind of content you'll
definitely see the benefits of the
MacBook Pro with its very color accurate
display extra ports and high performance
and you should therefore opt for the
$1,800 2019 MacBook Pro and if you have
a bit more cash left in your budget
upgrade to 16 gigabytes of RAM know if
you're doing those tasks almost everyday
and you take it very seriously you
should buy the base $2,400 15-inch
MacBook Pro especially video editors
since you get a dedicated graphics chip
photo editor should opt for 32 gigs of
RAM if they can since that will make the
biggest difference and that's the
highest config we recommend for photo
editors since you won't really get that
much of a boost going for the a core
processor video editor should instead
upgrade to 560 X graphics and if you
really want to upgrade storage too just
go back and choose the $2,800 model
instead because it brings you up to an a
core CPU and already comes with 560 X
graphics and 512 gigs of storage and if
you really want to go all out and have
the fastest machine possible go for the
Vega xx upgrade since it makes a huge
difference in video editing or
graphically intensive tasks so there you
have it guys we'll have links to the
different configurations down in the
description below and if this video
helped you out tap that like button and
click that circle above to subscribe so
you don't miss out on future videos like
the
what thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]